bonjour et bienvenue pour cet entretien
exclusif france 24 et radio france
internationale
c'est sans doute un tournant historique
le président français vient d'acter le
départ des forces françaises et
européennes du mali avec nous
aujourd'hui pour décrypter le message
présidentiel le porte-parole des forces
armées françaises colonel parce qu'elle
est ni bonjour bonjour merci de voeu
d'être venus si vite répondre aux
questions de france 24 et de franck
alexandre et fit alors tournant
historique la france se désengage du
mali est ce que c'est un constat d'échec
est ce que mon colonel on a perdu la
guerre au mali alors c'est effectivement
une décision significative qu'on peut
qualifier d'historique puisque nous
sommes en région mali depuis 2013 mais
comme l'a précisé le président de la
république on ne parle pas d'échec et
nous récusons le terme d'échec deux
défaites d'humiliation de déroute comme
on a pu l'entendre ou le lire au cours
d'eau au cours des dernières semaines
les armées françaises d'enquêté engagées
aux maliens en 2013 pour stopper des
colonnes de djihadistes les djihadistes
occuper la moitié du territoire malien
les armées françaises ont rempli la
mission qui leur avait été donné c'est à
dire vous permettre au mali de recouvrer
sa souveraineté sur l'ensemble de son
territoire les armées françaises ensuite
ont été engagés pour continuer la lutte
contre les groupes armés terroristes
tout en appuyant la montée en puissance
des forces armées maliennes et des
forces armées locales et ça s'est
traduit de manière très concrète puisque
les forces armées maliennes en 2013
c'était 7000 hommes faiblement équipés
faiblement entraîner d'une efficacité
opérationnelle toute relative
aujourd'hui les armées maliennes c'est
trente quatre mille hommes 40000 si on y
ajoute simi gendarmes qui sont à peu
près capable de faire face aux groupes
armés terroristes c'est une vraie
réussite et surtout en janvier 2020 on
nous a demandé on a demandé aux armées
françaises d'aller combattre les ges
dans la zone des trois frontières après
une série de massacres perpétrés
perpétrées contre les forces armées
nigériennes où les forces armées
maliennes à une d'elimane china gros
drame il n'a pas par exemple où les où
les armées locales ont perdu des
centaines d'hommes et nous avons rempli
la mission puisque aujourd'hui le sgs
n'a pas créé de khelifa territoriales
comme il prétendait le faire le geste
n'est plus capable de mener date sub de
submersion sur les forces locales donc
nous avons atteint les objectifs et je
voudrais souligner que éradiquer le
terrorisme en utilisant la seule force
militaire n'est pas la solution et
l'histoire nous le montrent les récentes
expériences nous le montre et au mali
c'est la même chose si on veut éradiquer
le terrorisme c'est aussi une réponse
politique social économique que le
message de ces corps de la retourne
amplement colonel oui mais là le la
décision qui a été prise
correspond à un état de fait et cet état
de fait il est imposé par
les autorités de transition et par la
jeune malienne c'est la responsabilité
de la junte malienne ce qui est en train
de se passer c'est elle qui porte la
responsabilité ce ne sont pas les armées
françaises il ya donc un problème
politique et est ce qu'on peut dire que
finalement l'intervention française
n'était plus comprise par la population
malienne la communication at elle était
d'une certaine façon votre talon
d'achille je pense qu'effectivement il
ya il ya un vrai sujet sur l'explication
de la présence militaire française dans
la bande sahélo saharienne et au mali en
particulier il y avait un vrai sujet de
communication nous avons communiqué nous
avons expliqué peut-être sans doute pas
assez c'est un vrai enseignement que
nous tirons de cette cette séquence qui
est en train de se de s'achever mais
j'aurais souligné aussi qu'il ya
peut-être une forme de deux sur
militarisation de la perception de
l'engagement de la france au sahel parce
que l'engagement français c'est aussi
des actions civiles de développement
c'est l'accession des actions dans
toutes sortes de secteurs et en fait on
a un peu trop fait le focus sur la seule
action militaire six mois pour se
désengager c'est très très rapide alors
le désengagement enfin l'arrêt
articulations de la force c'est-à-dire
concrètement le retrait des unités qui
sont aujourd'hui déployées sur le sol
malien va être une opération complexe
une opération logistique complexe et
surtout pendant cette opération
logistique nous allons continuer le
combat contre les groupes armés
terroristes parce que ne vont pas
arrêter de nous attaquer comment se
désengager et on continue combat en même
temps comment fait-on eh ben on élabore
des manoeuvres assez complexe on
s'engage sans aucun état d'esprit de
recul et ont rempli la mission qui nous
a été donnée et donc on nous a fixé un
délai de six mois il peut-être des aléas
climatiques puisque la saison des pluies
commence bientôt mais on tient nous
ferons tout pour tenir ce délai mais
pour autant le colonel le président
français a utilisé le terme continuité
est ce que c'est bien approprié de
parler de continuité alors qu'on est
poussé vers la sortie alors oui il y
avait un changement de stratégie qui a
été évidemment initié depuis le 10 juin
dernier on le sait mais est ce qu'on est
dans la continuité quand on plie bagage
en quatre à six mois qu'on quitte le
mali nous sommes parfaitement dans la
continuité parce que l'objectif c'est de
continuer la lute la lutte contre les
groupes armés terroristes dans la bande
sahélo saharienne est d'aider les pays
d'appuyer les pays du golfe de guinée à
prévenir l'implantation de ségou mêmes
groupes armés sur leur territoire la
continuité est parfaite et elle elle est
à nos yeux ou totalement évidente et
nous allons continuer ce combat avec la
même détermination de continuer au niger
ce sera le nouveau point d'ancrage de
l'intervention française alors quel
volume de force et où précisément au
niger alors le niger il était déjà prévu
que le niger devienne le centre de
gravité géographique du dispositif
militaire français dans la baisse
puisque vous souvenez quand juillet 2021
le président de la république et les
présents sahélien avait acté une
adaptation la force barkan qui s'était
traduite par la fermeture de trois ans
prise dans le nord du mali donc le niger
restera le centre de gravité
géographique de l'opération de lutte
contre les groupes armés terroristes il
n'est pas prévu d'augmenter
significativement les les effectifs au
niger au niger ne consomme conserveront
une base aérienne projetée et nous
conserverons un groupement tactique
désert qui dont la mission sera
d'accompagner les forces nigériennes au
combat ce qui est important c'est que le
futur est en train de se construire le
futur c'est une co réflexion une
réflexion commune avec les pays
africains avec les pays européens pour
aboutir à une codécision une décision
commune sur la façon dont nous allons
répondre de manière stratégique à la
menace terroriste dans la bande sahélo
saharienne et en afrique de l'ouest et
avec des soldats français qui ne seront
plus nécessairement aux premières lignes
c'est ça exactement le nous allons en
fait nous nous nous maintenons le
changement de modèle de parle de
paradigme qui avait été qui avait été
évoquée en juillet 2021 c'est à dire que
nous passons dans une posture d'appui et
de soutien aux forces armées locales
face aux groupes armés terroristes nous
répondons à leurs besoins ce sont elles
qui nous disent ce dont elles ont besoin
et nous apportons une réponse coordonnée
avec nos partenaires européens et nord
américains sssa l'élaboration de la
nouvelle stratégie de lutte contre le
groupe les groupes armés terroristes là
il ya un nouvel élément dans le
paradigme si je puis dire c'est l'axé
paris bamako moscou moscou le secret de
polichinelle des forces paramilitaires
sulfureuse de wagner colonel yannick
quelle preuve aujourd'hui avez-vous
tangible de l'existence on parle
maintenant d'un millier de parade
militaire de wagner sur le sol malien
quelles preuves tangibles pouvez vous
nous donner ce dans la mesure où du côté
malien et d'ailleurs on dit qu'ils n'y
sont pas de ce ne sont que des et des
forces régulières russe alors je ne vais
pas vous apporter de preuves issues de
sources de renseignement a maintenant ce
que je note c'est que le général tonnes
scène qui command africom a déclaré que
wagner a été présent mali je note que le
président de la république lors de son
sa conférence de presse le présent russe
lui à moscou lui a répondu que a reconnu
de fait la présence d'une société
militaire privée russe au mali la
question de wagner au mali c'est une
question qui concerne d'abord les
maliens parce que wagner c'est une
stratégie de presse de prédation
d'exactions on voit bien ce qui se passe
en république centrafricaine et surtout
de notre point de vue c'est ça
représente un vrai danger pour les
forces armées maliennes celle entrave à
la montée en puissance et la
restructuration des forces armées
maliennes qui a été qui a été engagée
depuis début 2013 puisque ce qu'on
constate en centrafrique c'est que
wagner en emploi les forces armées
centrafricaines les forces armées
locales de un peu par appartements des
structures ses forces armées et si c'est
la même chose au mali ça veut dire que
les progrès qui est interrogée au cours
des dernières années pourraient être
perdus est ce que c'est un des obstacles
des écueils dur du départ des forces
françaises au mali forces françaises et
européennes cette ligne rouge avec des
positions de wagner puisqu'on dit sur le
terrain que les paramilitaires de wagner
avance dans des zones qui ne sont plus
finalement si loin des vôtres je ne
considère pas que ce sera une entrave à
notre départ
dont coloniale est ce que vous allez
continuer à intervenir au mali depuis le
niger
la question vous posez en fait revient à
la question de la réassurance de la
mission des nations unies de la minus ma
aujourd'hui d'un d'un point de vue
militaire nous sommes bien sûr en cours
de réflexion est en cours des changes
avec la mission des nations unies pour
étudier les modalités de réassurance
sommes prêts à continuer à fournir des
missions de la science au profit de la
minus main mais si et seulement si les
autorités maliennes nous le demande
est-ce que vous pensez que soit l'avenir
aux russes et on va aussi étendre via
l'ukraine est ce que sur le la guerre
informationnelle le moscou et comme xiii
en avant sur sur la france il est il est
certain que en matière de fête news et
de désinformation les certains groupes
certains groupes d'intérêts russe ou pro
russe dispose de moyens considérables
on le on le constate dans la bande
sahélo saharienne et en afrique de
l'ouest et on on voit bien et on l'a
noté au cours des derniers mois que nous
sommes maintenant engagés dans une forme
de guerre informationnelle dans le champ
des perceptions et qu'aujourd'hui
l'opinion publique conquérir l'opinion
publique faire croire quelque chose à
l'aube biens publics est devenue une
action prépondérante le sel afghanistan
aux français ça vous irrite ça vous
passe au dessus quand on dit ce genre de
choses dont deux livreurs de choses je
pense que c'est que cette comparaison
n'a pas lieu d'être elle n'a pas lieu
d'être parce que les gars tu ne sont pas
les talibans les talibans étaient d'un
mouvement qui était au pouvoir qui avait
été renversé par l'intervention
américaine et internationale qui avait
pignon sur rue qui a disposé de
représentation diplomatique les gâte
correspondent pas à cela qu'on fermait
terroristes et sur les groupes armés
terrorisent pardon et et surtout encore
une fois nous avons atteint les
objectifs qui nous ont été qui nous ont
été fixés et je pense que ça n'a rien à
voir et je voudrais en profiter pour
avoir une pensée pour tous ceux qui sont
tombés au sahel soldats les militaires
français pour mes camarades blessés et
leurs familles et pour saluer leur
engagement qui témoigne de l'engagement
des armées françaises dans le combat
contre les groupes armés terroristes
merci colonel pascal yani c'est la fin
de cet entretien exclusif france 24 rfi
et merci de l'avoir suivi nos programmes
continus sur nos deux antennes
[Musique]